deshaun watson and patrick mahomes
squared off in the postseason for the
first time ever and
hey look it it has the makings chris and
you mentioned this during the game it's
got the makings of a new tom brady and
peyton manning but
but the texans have to put a defense on
the field or it's never going to be very
close because even with 24 points in
hand it wasn't nearly enough for deshawn
watson and company to hold off the
onslaught once the giant
woke up for the kansas city chiefs it it
was it did you just you could feel i've
never seen a momentum swing like that
uh where
a team was done and it's like it's over
and the five the fans are probably gonna
start leaving and then all it took was
that one moment and everything starts
going in kansas city's way and they
never look back drive after drive after
drive touchdown after touchdown after
touchdown and uh i you know i from the
texas standpoint i feel bad for him they
had their moment where they felt like
hey it's gonna be titans texans in the
afc championship game and then once the
doors blew off they were just gone for
good well i mean okay so there they are
you're right the chiefs come out they
lay an egg i mean it's like whoa blown
coverage first drive guy wide open for a
50-yard bomb touchdown hey block punt
drop punt by tyree kill you know another
nice little drive in between and nothing
holy cow we haven't even got going
what's going on
the great kick return jump starts them
that's what playmakers do that's why you
know first off you got to give andy reid
brett veach a lot of credit there
because that's why you draft playmakers
and they have a keen eye for that
because in those type of moments oh this
team's asleep oh crap what are we gonna
do nicole hardman you know these these
guys they have they can't wait to get
the ball i mean that's what kind of hurt
tyreek hill when he dropped the punt
they want to make a play i'll jump start
the team let's go well it finally
happened and then to your point you know
they the sleeping giant woke up well it
didn't help when bill o'brien put some
smelling stall in front of
them 24-7 to me this was the turning
point of the game it's 24-7
and kansas city yes had just scored a
touchdown but off of a short field and
had a penalty on that drive as well to
help the touchdown and it's fourth and
fourth and he calls the fake punt and
gives kansas city the short field again
to go hey i wasn't sure if the offense
got the momentum here but i just want to
make sure kansas city you guys got the
momentum now here we go we're going to
go for it i just didn't like the timing
of it i always like hey listen i'm for
aggressive i understand you want to
stomp a team out i just didn't think
that was the moment to do it they were
still in control of the game punt the
ball away try to pin them down there
kansas city had yet to drive the ball
down the full length of the field see if
they're going to do it but they kind of
jump started their engine and that was
it it was night night after that you
couldn't stop them
and i think what made it even worse
chris
running the fake punt in that spot up 17
points with a lot of game left the
message
whether he intended it or not
to his defense from bill o'brien was i
don't trust you guys to hold this lead
yeah i i think you're i mean i think
that's got to be a little bit of the
psychosis of guys running out there on
the field going you know i'm sure a lot
of the defensive guys don't know he's
going for the fake pun right so all of a
sudden they're they're whoa wait we got
to get out there here we go they're kind
of slowly butting up their chin straps
they're getting ready and then it's damn
okay our backs against you know the wall
here again we gotta we gotta be down
here close to the end zone and yeah i
think there's some some psycho analysis
there to your defense yeah i i you know
i don't trust you guys we gotta put them
away right now uh yeah you know that's
to me a play where you save for later in
the football game not in the second
quarter when you're controlling the
football game as is
to me it's one of those where okay maybe
it was 24-14 or 24-21
and now you're going all right i got to
do something to swing the momentum back
in my direction let me do it i don't
think momentum was totally with kansas
city here i think it still was like well
i think we can come back i mean at least
we got something positive going but then
they scored the touchdown here and then
you know mahomes went crazy when they
scored and you were like uh oh they're
back like watch out we're in store for a
game from here on out and that's what it
was and then it became not a game at all
because of what you said kansas city is
just unbelievable once they get rolling
you know the example i always use in
games like this the little brother
playing the big brother in ping pong and
when it was 21 nothing and little
brother is like hey here we go i'm on my
way i think the first moment little
brother became aware and started to get
a little nervous was when bill o'brien
went for the field goal instead of going
forward on fourth down yeah i'll tell
you what if they could have punched it
in again and made it 28 nothing right i
just think psychologically that makes it
a lot harder to come back from based on
what we saw from the chiefs yesterday
though they probably would have still
been able to do it right but that was
the first moment where everything's
going houston's way it's rolling it's
clicking it's clicking and when you back
off right you got your foot you got your
foot hovering over their throat right
and you consciously back off and then
you do the ridicul it really was
ridiculous and i know andy reid the
coach of the chiefs defended bill
o'brien after the game i mean he's just
being a good winner and also he's
thankful that the guy ran the fake punt
but that fake punt i think was
essentially throwing in the white towel
because you knew what was going to come
yeah and it came
51-7
think about what this game would have
been if the texans didn't get those
lucky breaks early on right with the
block punt and the muff punt it would
have been one of the all-time division
around blowouts chris yeah no you're
well kansas city was clearly the better
football team i think that's what when
the nerves of the game settled in
and kansas city stopped shooting
themselves in the foot
we you sat there and watched and he went
oh man kansas city is clearly better
here you know with mahomes play-making
ability they got aggressive on the
offensive side of the ball finally you
know again kansas city they got to stop
letting some of these teams play
man-to-man on them they they gotta
attack more and i think that's finally
what they did by holmes and company they
finally just said you know we got to
start throwing the ball 15 25 30 yards
down the field at least we'll get past
interference do things like that and you
know i think that's what they got going
the texans were playing in their face
and then mahomes got rolling started
making plays kelsey does a great job
when mahomes scrambles you know mahomes
took the game over oh it's man-to-man oh
there's a lane to run there's nobody
playing me man and all you guys are
chasing my receivers down so there's
backs turn he made a number of big plays
scrambling that's why to me
the best quarterback in the nfl right
now and you know this hurts me to say
because i love number 12 up in green bay
but the best guy in the game right now
is number 15 in red over there and his
coach is big red he's just amazing what
he does the place he makes the
leadership the calmness all of it to me
is is top notch and he's the best in the
sport for my money
and chris i think one of the reasons
that the chiefs got overlooked as the
season progressed beyond
the new bright shiny object being lamar
jackson and what the ravens are doing
what the 49ers are doing and the chiefs
lost some games at home but once patrick
mahomes got injured he had the ankle
injury from week one against the jaguars
that hobbled him for several weeks then
you throw the knee injury on top of it
that he suffered on that quarterback
sneak against the broncos on a thursday
night
he never really had gotten back to being
the guy
who could do all the other things other
than and you know if all you have is a
rocket arm
you're going to be well served as an nfl
quarterback but when you augment that
with the ability to move the the launch
pad wherever you want however you want
and you throw 53 rushing yards he said
after the game the one thing that jumped
off the stat sheet adam was he had 53
rushing yards he led the team in rushing
seven attempts 53 yards and when you
have that mobility back again you're
even more dangerous and it's 2018 all
over again and you don't have the
patriots coming in for the afc
championship game it's really something
he probably needs to be a hair more
aware of you know and they put such
great stress on the defense with the way
they're built yeah his mobility's top
notch as we saw whether it's scrambling
extending a plays i mean come on some of
those touchdown passes on third and goal
to travis kelsey i mean none of them
were open those are just two guys making
unbelievable plays my homes were doing a
great job of like finding a whole buy in
time kelsey doing a great job going wow
i'm totally covered let me find a hole
to let this freak of nature mahomes just
throw me some ball and you know of
course he did and kelsey made some great
catches uh but yeah mahomes is just a
phenomenal talent and you know even you
know again early on
he wasn't off right i mean the team was
letting him down receivers were letting
him down yeah he missed the ball you
know could have maybe thrown a hair more
accurately here and there but i mean
kelsey dropped robinson drop i mean he
came out ready to play uh so he is just
an unbelievable talent amazing you know
one more thing too do you mind if i go
here just back to the yes do you do all
right the hell with you anyways well you
always do that no i ever tell you no no
you don't okay fine i'm doing it it's 24
nothing you're right the field goal
right they're up 21-0 it's fourth and
one looks like they're gonna go for it
there must be some you know
miscommunication on the sidelines
between billy o'brien the guy putting in
the personnel right and then he decides
to kick the field goal i'll say this i
don't have an issue with him kicking the
field to go up 24 nothing i get it but
at that m and i get like the naysayers
out there oh you go for the kill first
of all it was the middle of the second
quarter there's a lot of time a lot of
football to be played
second thing i would argue is you know
hey you go up 24 nothing you're making a
team to come back they got to score
three touchdowns they got to score six
touchdowns three touchdowns two
two-point conversions so i think he's
going out like that and to that point of
the game kansas city had shown no
ability really to drive the ball so i
think he's thinking okay i'll just take
this go up 24 nothing maybe we get a
stop again if i kick a field goal i go
up 27 nothing and it's a four score
football game uh so you know it didn't
work out that way but i didn't have
chris with that one but but i still
think that and especially the wavering
there and we're gonna go for we're gonna
kick it that was the first moment that
little brother realized i really
shouldn't be winning against big brother
in ping pong the way i am maybe it's not
gonna lie and it's probably not gonna
last right maybe you're right i mean
maybe that's what billy o'brien yeah i i
don't know i don't know what his logic
was there you know the exciting thing
yeah the exciting thing about the game
was this too once it's 24 nothing like
we're going to see something special
we're either going to see the chiefs get
knocked off at home and the texans
advance to an all houston afc
championship or we're going to see a
great comeback and my money was on the
comeback like didn't we all have a sense
this is the chiefs at some point they
are going to wake up and the question is
will they do it with enough time
remaining to overcome however many
points the texans have i mean i think
even even when it felt as dark and as
bleak as it could have gotten yeah right
there was a sense they're gonna they're
gonna find a way to dig their way out
yeah that's it's valid you're right
because it's like we were just talking
about it wasn't like you know kansas
city it wasn't like the second half of
their first matchup where kansas city
was getting pushed all over the field
and carlos hyde and everybody was
controlling the clock you felt like
physically they were the better the team
they were just screwing it up so i
you're right that's a very real point um
kansas city just so talented and the
defense once again i mean showing what
they're all about yeah okay they were
down 24 nothing it had nothing to do
with the defense other than that blown
coverage on the first drive i mean i
don't know what you know what do you
want them to do but they're impressive
it's a different defense the texans
couldn't run the ball and control the
clock that way even when they were up
24-0 or 24-7 so kansas city's the real
deal they really are they have they have
turned the corner as far as being a much
much more balanced football team and uh
that game's only going to give them even
more confidence and i don't know if
they're a group that needs that much
more confidence
and by advancing the two seed now host
the afc championship game because the
one seed couldn't get it done on
saturday night at home against the
titans tennessee baltimore we'll talk
about that one when pft live continues
right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports